okay online hello everyone I do believe
this is live just decided to create
another tournament since the the last
one went so well
hey already we have we have a lot of
viewers a eminence wrote wrote PvP hello
Ryan Clark
Cleo D'Souza gamer champion mr. Blackie
hello everyone
Nathan Anthony Barbour good to see you
all as usual okay I see that a lot of
you already joined the tournament very
nice for those of you who are here for
the first time this is elite chess
tournament number 16 as so far I've done
16 tournaments on the stream the way you
join in a Dave peers
hello man the way you join in you have a
link in the description below you just
click on the link and the password is
YouTube 16 since it's tournament number
16
no chronal DUI I don't really enjoy
football or soccer for that matter a
football is some a croatia is playing
greece that that is what you're saying
my bed then I didn't know there was a
football match going on Siva Kumar is
ready to play very nice
okay 23 players so far it's a three plus
so tournament as some of you know I
really hate that increment unless it's a
classical game then then I enjoyed the
increment but for Bloods games no
increment is the best increment Nabil
mujadid II hello man Diego Sosa says
that football is like chess well of
course if you if you consider that a
football match is actually two to chest
train to whole football trainers playing
against each other
you are writing a test tomorrow well
nothing like nothing like a blitz
tournament before a test mr. Blackie
says that it would be a pretty cool
thing if I would play a match with motto
I don't really think motto ever plays
online chess as far as I know although
although he did draw a game against the
Boris Spassky in a simultaneous
exhibition a hello white phantom
Ronaldinho says it's one to zero for
Croatia or for Greece or or whoever is
playing for Croatia very nice both of a
clown
oh it's both of the clown okay from
Canada where is motto motto okay so we
have 52 players so far very nice the
tournament starts in 13 minutes so we
can play a warm-up game if anybody is
interested or we can just chill until
the tournament starts but I'll just
check it in another link to see if we
have any three minutes or less would be
preferred no increments oh because
that'll last forever okay we have a we
have a three plus no challenge from a
high wall okay good luck man
else Pierrot don't be afraid to play
humans humans are the best
hey it's Gaspar from Brazil subdued okay
let's go for some for some Russian
trickery our opponent isn't interested
so I guess we'll just have to continue
developing what about st. Louis chess
club what about it
Thiago Silva okay I was just so pretty I
don't expect this to be a some fancy
game since we're both just developing
pieces but you never know what what's my
plan here since I have since I'm black I
definitely want to exchange some pieces
and perhaps even the dark square bishop
yes let's exchange that bad boy and get
our rooks into the game somehow is
Alicia's rating lower or higher it
depends really it depends where you are
from okay I definitely want to exchange
this maybe even a rook yeah you can
still play of course the tournament
starts in like 10 minutes our opponent
is playing really fast so I'm thinking
I'm thinking about a c5 but it doesn't
work here let's get our rook into the
game
Dave Pierce did I ever get your donation
I will have to check although although I
don't think so
I don't think I remember a Dave Pierce
although although if I have I probably
would have mentioned it definitely what
do you have before here okay now how the
c-5 seem now not really like like the
greatest choice let's try and get a look
in there somehow
my favorite opening I don't have a
favorite opening but pretty much
anything anything that involves beef or
is pretty good still just trying to
activate my rook somehow okay is this a
good move or what I'm just gonna occupy
the e-file
once again okay here's my chance to to
exchange Queens but do I want to not
really not really I'll just ignore even
for a moment okay let's get the g6 in
there and h5 maybe where is the accent
from it's from Croatia and also Cartoon
Network probably okay he wants to
exchange rooks of course he does just
gonna ignore him and accept it like this
and probably push now since the Queen
doesn't really have a way of entering my
position he wants to capture on h6 but
this will have to wait
I might even allow him I'm gonna allow
him to capture on h6 since that's it's
not the greatest move
huh also very long time yet I saw that
okay definitely have to go for h5 here
[Music]
okay
let's push here don't really mind Quincy
one is definitely what he's gonna play I
don't see a better move than Quincy one
and then I have a queen d4 probably but
we'll see capturing and g3 is also an
idea so should be okay okay this is
checkmate song but a great game great
game and he played very fast is the dog
were watching cartoons
well not really the dog is pretty much
afraid of of cell phones and smartphones
and he doesn't understand it no I have
never played shogi dimitris wants to
know who is playing mobile legends my
girlfriend my girlfriend is playing
mobile legends at the moment so that's
seven more minutes till the start of the
tournament we have a hundred and nine
players very nice
it's Colonel Dean you're playing I don't
seek Ronaldinho here he's probably too
busy watching that crazy uh grease a
soccer game okay
we probably it's like seven minutes so
we do have time for one more warm up
game caveman was here first so if Kaman
caveman is still in the challenges yes
he is good at two plus so best book and
chess are that's a tough one
there are so many good books on chess
and good luck to you mr. caveman
Halloween gambit plus one am I married
no no I'm not married I do live with my
girlfriend for five years now so it's
pretty much the same thing
okay it's a two plus also I do have to
play a bit faster not really what I was
going for don't really want to exchange
the dark square bishop here this is this
is not what I wanted to play at all it's
completely not my not my game let's go a
five Luminas girl just took the biggest
dump at work that's that's wonderful to
hear
Brooksie one okay I do have to develop
my pieces somehow although it's not not
at all clear how I definitely don't want
to allow him to push c5 so let's go
Bishop e7 rook c8 and try to develop
like this try and stay ahead of time
that bishop on c4 is ready to be
attacked
okay still thinking you gave up smoking
and embraced vaping I tried the vape but
I tried the cheap one so I didn't really
enjoy it's probably gonna go bishop b1
and go for some chick mating ideas on h7
so definitely have to have to be careful
about things like this although he's
spending a lot of time K Knight goes
here if I capture capture definitely
worth considering but Knight here is
also coming probably like this I have to
capture the rook first capture here
capture capture probably okay and I have
a Bishop c5 not allowing him or this
this brings up a lot of questions
actually so allow do I allow him to
capture the b6 long don't really think I
can
but mmm just gonna capture this pawn
instead not because I want to capture a
pawn but I don't want to allow him any
rook tempest on the D file
yeah caveman looks like like a real
player Queen c7 okay I'm I do have some
pawns so I don't mind trading actually
okay let's trade few trades Queens I
don't mind playing this at all should be
completely winning okay let's get a rock
into the game let's grab that phone with
check and simply push our points to
victory let's exchange that rook and
block and get a queen
this is a very much winning good game
the password bro is YouTube 16 as this
is tournament number 16 yeah I don't
want to repeat it for for people who are
here for the first time you can enter
the tournament with the link from the
description below you just entered the
password YouTube 16 and you join us and
well 144 players so far that are
registered for the tournament
[Music]
okay just making some last-minute
preparations I do I just I didn't ask
you if if the audio is okay but since
you seem to understand what I'm saying
peekaboo is ready alright peekaboo very
nice why not everybody here drop a
thumbs up I don't really see the thumbs
I only see the thumbs after I finish the
stream bash fluff is 140 fifth out of
146 players very nice so you can only go
up from there man
science when did I start smoking I don't
know probably some 15 years ago
recreationally Nana fire I probably just
have to click that little Bell button
that's like a new YouTube thing it's not
enough to just subscribe you also have
to click the little Bell button to get
notified it's very annoying
just another I'm not just one of the way
YouTube trolls you hey I didn't watch
what is up greetings from Bosnia Thank
You Man do I smoke weed no I don't smoke
weed that is illegal man
favorite type of music don't really have
a favorite type but if it's quality
music I don't really mind the genre the
tournament will be I believe I set it to
one hour so should be enough to play at
least
well maybe ten games definitely the best
player I played against online or over
the board or what do you mean both of
the clown says he can see the girlfriend
I don't I don't think you can that's
that's that's impossible
and we have a countdown hey Abdul HB
favorite chess book okay and we're
starting the tournament it's a three
plus so so let's enjoy and our opponent
seems to have berserk okay I will not
preserve back since I don't want to read
the chat as the well I'm just gonna go
for some b6 ideas let's go like this try
to focus all of my attention to this
efore pawn we'll see what our point
decides to do let's go here let's
capture that that bad boy uh-huh and c5
c5 should be okay
Knight here this does leave my Bishop
here but what are you gonna do I just
capture here capture here and castle
nicely this does leave me open to some
Bishop to h7 attack but
I'm just gonna try it he probably will
go for it as he did berserk but we'll
see I might even give up my queen for
for King captures and Queen captures but
he's not gonna go for it
so that's weird I really thought he
would go for it
let's go rook here if yours back need a
Bishop d3 I will have to play something
like age 7 h6 sorry not allow any any
mating ideas oh he's gonna go for the
bishop b1 very nice okay so I don't have
to get my knight back into the defense
because he does have some sneaky plans
probably with Knight g6 or maybe even
Knight f5 to pressure here but let's
exchange this bishop if he accepts the
day okay of course he won't now we just
get the night into the game how do we
improve the rook I can't really improve
my queen since although I can like this
what see what's the idea with Queen III
laughs he wants to push my night away oh
he wants to push my night away let's
just capture here and force an exchange
but this will only this will not help me
ha
uh-huh let's try like this and then if
Bishop if Bishop b4 I have queen c3 then
then rook d3 yeah this doesn't work
so I guess I'll just capture it I don't
really see why I shouldn't really didn't
want to capture it but oh okay that does
win like that but I don't think it's
it's worth it let's let's go f5 here
definitely worth considering okay not
really interested let's capture here now
that would allow him some drawing ideas
if he pushes I don't mind so I just
played rook c4 if he pushes I can stop
it always
okay let's exchange pretty much has to
do it let's push this guy forward if he
pushes still I can just block or I don't
really have to let's go here he does
only have four seconds so just gonna
block it like this threaten checkmate he
does
stop checkmate with this but not for
long not for long
let's go like this I don't think he has
time okay berserk King was a bit too
optimistic here okay we won the game and
we were thirty second place very nice
def is currently in the first place but
since there are a lot of players will
have to check will have to check on in a
couple of minutes
no Tim no I don't have any titles
unfortunately he goes for the Kings
gambit oh go for the counter gambit for
the folk beers
counter gambit which is always always a
fun thing not if three let's just pin it
this is a so weird move I've never met
this idea before so we'll just capture
this bad boy and follow up with catch
with Knight to f6 this seems okay push
if I could play against the sparrow or
Tull who would I choose well I would
definitely choose against the doll since
Sparrow is still alive you know there's
still chance for me to play Kaspar of
here and there Bishop c5 allows d4 I'm
not too crazy about that although I
don't really have a choice I kind of do
want a castle maybe oh he will go for
the b4 not really interested in that
either c4 probably no okay I'll just
castle still don't know what his idea is
now he goes for this I don't think this
is good
allowing my rook to come to e8 with such
such great tempo yeah I have a title
youtube master yeah that's that's funny
okay well what's what's the idea here
let's go Queen e7 threatened some
threatening some Queen e1 okay he sees
that how do we improve here well I don't
want to allow rook d1 so I'll go Bishop
f2 just for fun and we'll see where that
leads
rook f1 mm-hmm so probably probably not
the best move but how do we get the
Queen into the game night here to c5
that seems
a reasonable idea am i playing in
tournaments for money no yeah he did go
for this as I if I go here he'll just
push me away
so I don't have to go back this this
wasn't really a good plan but I do have
some ideas of c-5 this Bishop doesn't
have any good discoveries so I'm not
really worried a Thomson's from Latia
greetings man okay he's not interested
I'll just grab here and probably
sacrifice the night here that seems like
a reasonable think although first of all
Rock d8 then maybe maybe try it in 94 if
he does if it doesn't go Bishop to f3
Bishop to f3 would have been a better
move I think let's go here if he now
goes Bishop to f3 or this I'll just
check in here then I might even consider
if King here okay
don't really have have any ideas for
what to play here I'll just exchange oh
threatening Queen captures on h7 that's
very unfortunate
very unfortunate really no good way to
stop this it's a very unfortunate how
did I blunder this ha
oh that's just that's just bad have to
give up the Queen I totally miss this
yeah Queen h4 man I've missed Queen h4
about what are you gonna do what are you
gonna do yep
let's transfer our attention here yeah
that's that's that's nice and 16 seconds
this is this is crazy okay let's try
some try some sneaky moves I don't think
it it'll work but I do have to try
something yeah that's that's the best
okay I have to go back seven seconds to
go
[Music]
okay is that okay good game yeah I
missed that Queen h4 that was very
unfortunate but okay Emery Betsy you
joined the tournament by clicking on the
link in the description below and the
password is YouTube 16 I know I've never
been to Lithuania yeah I'm still working
on the I'm still working on the on the
opening and the chair gambit opening
yeah that was a that was a very feisty
game okay seems we have to go for the
for the fried liver we'll see what our
opponent plays here
he doesn't go for the instant Bishop e5
tricks so maybe he is considering
something else but no he does go for it
oh okay let's go h6 here in d4 after he
retreats if he goes off you guys he's
gonna go back then we have Bishop d6 I
think is the correct response yeah I do
have to capture it now unfortunately I
don't wanna don't want to lose sight of
c6 I don't think white is playing this
really as he should but okay probably no
still not castling okay then I'll just
stop me from castle and altogether if he
captures I don't really mind this bishop
on e6 is so powerful I even want to give
up my rook for this guy
and how do we do that there's no reason
to do it immediately Queen there okay
let's just lock the position here's a
trained eye greetings from Hanover and
from Poland very nice okay he's gonna
have a really hard time developing here
and he really wants to take my rook I
don't really mind let's let me just
check a couple of options here I don't
really need this rook it's pretty
useless rook
if you capture as I capture and my dia
is Knight g4 don't really see if he can
stop this easily still has to develop
this Bishop or or denied he can't castle
so not really worried there maybe have
three but this simply allows my rook to
get into the game with tempo Thank You
Boston ski okay we're still still
waiting to see what slick my stuff will
come up with a greeting greetings from
South Africa Thank You Man
John Smith the password is YouTube 16 as
it says in the description below always
the next tournament the password will be
of course YouTube 17 and the tournament
after that you cube 18 and so on
hello from Iran and from Syria very nice
yeah but uh okay he did go for four
night here but I think 94 is simply
enough here okay he did go for that so
how about how about harassing the rook
don't really wanna okay although I could
have captured it at that's what I get
for not thinking okay so let's just
captured the rook as well hello I'm
first gonna capture the night it seems
like I can capture pretty much anything
I want
yeah look please just as well
probably just waiting for me to blunder
something okay the route goes back
Knight goes back because we are okay
rook if one
I'll just capture the guy okay let's go
here and that's checkmate very nice okay
waiting to come back into the into the
tournament do we have any berserkers
around linetsky Hebrews irked one game
so he does have first place only one
with 13 points sometimes it's very nice
to berserk hey Alan yeah man I do
remember you mister thank you matter is
having a raid okay Esteban Esteban oh
eight good luck to you man
so go for efore okay we have the
Sicilian we'll go for B for for no
particular reason
as usual we'll see what happens
if Knight f6 I usually go a 5k d4 was
just pin this night here if a six okay
it's definitely the way to go although
though I might play e5 now instead
give him something to think about
a spelling mistake first time okay we
have Knight d5 they're made there may be
some ideas of Queen coming into the game
but if a capture capture castle or
capture here castle he'll go Bishop to
e7 probably I'll go c4 maybe maybe
activate maybe I have to be my queen
side for for that pawn I sacrificed but
we'll see okay
I'll capture if he captures backup
capture so probably castle and then I
have a d5 to activate my bishop that
should be that should be okay what time
is it here it's it's 9:30 p.m. do I
dream about chess oh well you know
sometimes definitely okay now if i push
d5 he will have time for Bishop e6 so
not really crazy about that but where's
the night going the night has to go back
and this is why I like this so Knight
has to go back I will capture on d7 and
then he doesn't have Bishop f6 that's
that's very nice where do I live I live
in Croatia yeah in Croatia Jarvis says
it right of course it's also 9:30 in
Poland but he's prepared to capture with
the knight to the weasel I'll just go
Bishop d3 try and activate my bishops
for I did sacrifice a pawn I do have to
get at least something for it if only I
could get my knight into the game
quickly he's probably gonna go for
Bishop f6 at some point yeah matter is
also creation
you have crippling depression thank you
man
what's with creations and YouTube
channels I don't know I guess guess
people people here really really enjoy
it although although not that many
jari first time to go check out the live
stream and I don't think Esteban is
actually thinking this long I think he's
actually offline
I believe this gray button says that he
is not with us anymore
that's very unfortunate last les
tournament I believe we had two cheaters
in the tournament so that's very
unfortunate but there's really nothing I
can do about this I lost the game to a
cheer and a couple of other players also
lost their games to a cheater but other
than lowering the time format I really
don't have a way of of making this
better thank you thank you rich want do
I get afraid when I see my opponent has
a Russian name no not really
yeah cheetahs in using a computer as if
they used an engine yes but you don't
use it on the same computer you can use
it on a laptop or something but still
leeches will leech s we'll find out they
probably have some good algorithm that
you know compares the moves
ok let's sacrifice a couple of points
here since he did play h6 it's really I
don't think it's something that should
even be considered but since he did play
that I will try to sacrifice a couple of
points to get some moves into int into
the game
yeah leeches detects it almost
immediately if Bishop 3:6 I might even
go rocky one so but he'll probably go
now he can't go Bishop e7 she has to
play Bishop e6 and then rook e1 is
definitely an idea
I think rook e1 is is a is an idea here
am i planning more videos on niche MIDI
knows well of course
Najma tinos games are the best
okay let's snatch that Queen and grab
the bishop as well if knight c6 yeah
that Bishop is pretty stranded there I
don't play the English opening really
but I think any opening is is a good
opening you know if it's good for you
I mean openings are like pretty much
like weapons all of them are great if if
they suit you you need mortal videos
okay I am definitely gonna make mortal
videos I already made one today I didn't
make another one I just still haven't
published it I will publish it after the
tournament favorite player of all okay
I'll take the bishop well yes I mean
it's pretty understandable he's right
above me actually you can see him there
let's go Queen f3 I don't know any move
is pretty okay here
yeah I'll just grab this spawn here okay
get the other rook into the game maybe a
queen g3 g3 is definitely an idea what
do I think about morphe well morphe is
the man what is there to think about
more fit more fees the man ah he does
have Knight h5 here that's very annoying
but loses the rook so it's not really a
problem at all
okay get our knight in there pushes the
pawn I check made him if he doesn't I
check made him all as well
ah he'll play it like this okay but it's
still checkmate so okay good game goose
T boost you lover boy okay we're back to
our winning streak so let's try to
maintain it can I make a video on tall
verses Paul carries both eras but I'm
pretty sure you meant Karis although I'm
not saying that there isn't a chess
player called Paul Ferris not at all
will I play bonk cloud I mean no no I
will not that's that's four players far
above my level no George I'm not an I am
okay this is something to consider
he didn't go for the main line of the
gambit but I'm pretty sure I can capture
here although I just I might be just
blundering my queen I don't know
okay I can capture here the bonk cloud
is the best bong and the best cloud and
I it's a it's something you play to
really show that that you're very strong
okay
our opponent resigned here since he he
doesn't want to play without a queen
okay so we climbed up the 11th place 269
players playing so far less tournament
we had almost 300 I think it was 290
something or don't really remember we're
playing against moto lock he plays it
efore as well thank you Chris thank you
thank you Chris let's go for some
Russian ideas as well
let's go Bishop c5 hopefully to stop d4
but there's definitely something he
wants to go for Bishop retreats I'll
just push the night away here I might
even consider capturing an f2 since he
did kind of under develop here so I'll
just do it not saying it's a good move
I'm just saying I'll do it and how does
he stop huh if I check him
I think this is okay
huh okay I do get a lot of bones for the
piece I don't really mind and he didn't
really manage to develop any of his
queenside pieces so pretty sure this
will be okay my voice still sounds like
Jose Mourinho's yeah I did get that a
lot
actually yeah that is the best move with
the King definitely I do have to stop
the King from escaping so if he goes III
I can simply Castle pretty sure my okay
this is just losing immediately
okay good game mr. moto lock
will I make some tutorial videos about
gambits and openings us a lot of people
are asking me that but I don't know what
there are a lot of videos like that
already on YouTube so I'm definitely
considering it I just haven't really
figured out how to go about it
okay mr. prana pues
mr. piranhapus let's go efore should we
go for some Kings gambit I haven't
played Kings gambit yet although nobody
really accepts the gambit anymore but
mr. pran opposed us okay he doesn't go
for any lines
so I'll just develop normally he'll go
Bishop g4 probably I'll go
no he won't so I'll just castle favorite
chess match a full time oh that's uh
that's a tough question that's a tough
question I'm just gonna play Bishop f7
he doesn't wanna take it that's really
weird hey thank you Hawk in Korea and
now he wants to get rid of him okay I
accept it
am i fan of Modric everyone is a fan of
moderator I guess the favourite
swearword in creation I'm not sure if I
can say it on YouTube do I have to
capture the night or do I capture he
captures on f6 if he captures rook I
capture on e7 and he can't really bring
back the night into the game so pretty
sure this is better
where's the dog the dog is somewhere
probably in the kitchen
ah yeah he figured it out he didn't
allow me to trick him unfortunately
let's capture here maybe Bishop g5 next
move if I check and check and check he
loses okay I think Knight g5 check is
fine since if he captures I capture with
the check if he moves the King I pick up
the bishop yeah this is a trick he does
have to stop the check somehow okay I
also capture with check so that that
definitely didn't help if he pins
I'll check simply move back this is
super fine for me
Thank You Audra Andrew Wolfson glad you
enjoyed the content hey Zack no I don't
live in America I live in Croatia let's
just to go Bishop h4 since there don't
seem to be a way for him to actually
escape this okay so how about just
grabbing here she wants to go rogue g8
but Bishop stops this immediately or do
I even have to I don't know let's get
the king somewhere yeah like that if he
goes to the darks were just Bishop
captures is fine I guess
kingi a tricky one and this is plenty I
don't really play that many chests many
chess games today probably mostly I
sometimes play a bullet or hyper bullet
nah my god isn't American man
okay so we although we lost one game we
managed to climb up again against the
Shrek Meister
we already played one game so don't
remember if I was a let's go Bishop c4
what do I play against d4 i if i knew he
was gonna go a let's go for a knight g5
it's it's only fair I mean it's it's the
correct thing to do when someone offers
it you go for it it's probably still
thinking about it I think we actually
play the same variation only I was black
yeah I if I knew he was gonna play it
like this I would have played it okay he
just allowed c7 so so that's unfortunate
miss your Ronaldo I'm not really into
soccer but definitely definitely messy I
don't really like that Ronaldo guy okay
so we got the Queen still our opponent
will play this so okay let's go D for D
for ya rook e1 that that my point is 27
this is this is great if he pins it with
the rook I'll just capture the bishop
here so I can grab another Queen if okay
he doesn't want to go for it
was just develop capture here okay I
don't really mind this if he grabs my
rook I have 97 of course he will capture
that first but I have check and after he
moves
I can pretty much okay that's that's
just not good so let's just attack it
one more time
Fisher or niche Medina what do you mean
if Fisher plane is Medina who would win
okay let's grab the rook although I
could have captured with the Queen for
an for a checkmate in two but let's
let's just have some fun
okay let's grab this rook as well okay
good game mr. Shreck my stop okay we
clung climb to a third place 282 players
very nice even though we lost that
unfortunate game in the beginning let's
let's try and Oh mr. Tomac a swan is in
first place and so far he won 546 rating
points very nice okay II five it is so
the fog bear gambit it is let's go
Bishop g4 if he captures what is kind of
forced to capture here if Knight here
do I have to okay I will capture go like
this
d4 I don't want to capture on pass on
definitely on before I have to this is
actually good for white I don't think I
played this correctly
but okay it is what it is I can capture
here although this is leaving my king in
the center but I will try it it's a bit
of risky but he does have d3 or even d4
he's gonna go for d3 so it wasn't really
worth it but what are you gonna do yeah
if we will capture with the knight of
course so it's a pretty pretty equal
game he has a 4 to 3 and on the Queen
side I have 3 to 2 on the Kings side so
I guess endgame it is but ok he allows
me to double up his pawns so I'll just
do it he does have a bishop against
tonight Bishop f4 is certainly looking
very pleasing yeah he does play it so
they capture it
I don't want I'll just go like this
she'll try to double up here although he
can't really you really want to go for
this y'all go like this and get rid of
my who captured the night that's
definitely an option but who played
better Fisher Arnage Medina well I mean
Fischer played better that's not really
something to discuss
let's go f6 here not yeah I will capture
with the rook not with the pawn I don't
want to double up my own pawns as well
and I'm leaving this spawn as a weakness
so now he his deck in here and he wants
to double up I'll just attack here he'll
go b3 or B for now he will double up
unfortunately so uh he won't okay
I don't mind really he will lock my rook
out of the game but I don't think he can
let's just attack this guy if he
captures I capture first this pawn and
then the a pawn
okay first this pawn okay he's not
allowing me to capture the a pawn let's
just lock the King out of the game first
he wants to check made me so it's very
unfortunate although I will try to
escape I wanted to do my chart over out
of a rope sending let's do bad let's go
here if he captures I'll capture back if
he can if he attacks the C pawn LOC 5
nope won't allow that
okay I could have just captured that
that's that was pretty silly of me
actually now threatening here and also
threatening to checkmate him there
however we'll see
it's just get he'll out checkmate very
unfortunate he was so worried about
saving that phone that I it happens
okay good game me 7a okay still in third
place everyone seems to be winning a lot
of players with a lot of points here 294
players okay this might be the
tournament we break 300 but we'll see
yeah Boyan EFT says it well in real life
rating is about it was 2000
seventy I lost the game so probably
about 2050 we're up against a Yishai 99
do I like salmon no not really
currently Dubai currently you mean a
living chess player C Phi that's a
that's an odd move the the French is
Sicilian and also the d5 okay
let's kind of force him to push c4 it's
not interested okay uh let's just
develop as many pieces as we can since
he he started off with some slow moves
when does the eigen matter world tour
begin well hopefully soon but we'll see
you know what's the idea here if he
wants to capture upon I don't really
mind if he captures the pawn
I said that don't like Anand style of
playing it's not that I don't like only
on style of playing I don't like pretty
much any modern player style of playing
its I know I know it's a very strong but
it's also it's also quite most of the
times lifeless that doesn't really have
anything to do with on Anu I was just
doing a video on arm so okay I was kind
of expecting that let's get the rock
into the game with tempo I kind of don't
want him to castle so I'll try to try to
delay it for as long as I can if I play
Bishop c4 he can capture on f3 yeah I do
have to go for h3 unfortunately and kind
of allow him to castle vasily smyslov
challenges me it's it's like a dream
come true
okay now Bishop f5 and do I have hmm I
really feel like this could be exploited
somehow with a move like Bishop c4 maybe
with some ideas of 9595 if he captures
rook captures or maybe even rocky five
rocky five seems interesting Rocky five
attacking okay we'll try rocky five
seems like a weird move but if he
totally ignores it which he does then
it's a bad move yeah it was worth right
a try okay let's go back that looks like
your dog
awaken or tile who played better it's
hard to say both of them were artistic
in their own way
okay he wants to exchange Bishop's so
many pieces in here I definitely want to
do something about that probably should
have left that rook on e5 okay let's
let's go like this will I ever do a
classical tournament I don't think yeah
my rook is said that they said it well
III won't do a classical tournament
because even in blitz tournaments like 3
plus or 2 plus so people are still
cheating so really no point in doing a
classical tournament
kruky 8 I can't really double up so a
knight of 3 this does leave my bishop
undefended but if he captures I'll
capture defending the bishop maybe f4 94
seems scary I don't like 94 although a
four bit on now Bishop b5 is a threat
that's definitely play Bishop b5 can you
stop this somehow I don't think he can
how can you cheat in chess all very
easily very easily I don't think he has
any more options here
would I kill my dog to get training from
towel of course not
what kind of question is that man okay
hmm I will grab the rook since I don't
really have a better move and here try
to try to try to do something about this
Queen she still don't really like this
I'll go I'll transfer my rook here if he
pushes the pawn that's not really a good
move and now I have 95 to get my knight
into the game and seems okay yeah f4
seems like an idea he still can't push
the pawn I think I mean he can but
doesn't really achieve anything okay he
will should probably hurry up here don't
have too much time on my hands okay oh
oh no I didn't know I was so low on time
he has like 1/10 of a second damn it's
uh it's one of the problems when I'm
streaming I don't hear the sound of the
moves so I don't realize that the move
has been made I would have to wear
headphones to hear the sound which I
sometimes I do if I play bullet but I
don't know I thought for blitz it wasn't
necessary but I've been proven wrong
with tomorrow is Burger King us okay I
just watched the game so I will berserk
back with some a five ideas okay let's
capture probably d5
see five seems okay go here I can't
capture the point because I'll capture
the night
f-five seems like an idea although not
yet not yet definitely okay let's grab
this guy and here okay I will capture
this one although I don't really need it
don't really need this ball I'll just
leave it there yeah I don't have any
mods yet like I said when I'll be doing
a longer stream I will then get some
mods Bishop to h3 is definitely a threat
here since there really was no reason to
to grab this c5 points it really seems
like a useless pawn just gonna start
some sort of a pawn storm here I do have
to develop my bishop though not going to
allow the nights to come to f3 I
definitely wouldn't enjoy that yeah
what's not allowing any ideas ether III
is now a threat he probably has to do
something about it with moves like
Knight c4 ok he is not gonna do anything
about this so I'll just take advantage
of it I like that ok
ok sir you're still not out of the woods
okay
I don't mind
okay let's just protect it like this
okay I'm pretty sure I can win this with
without a problem okay I just don't hear
the Moose when when they've been played
yeah he doesn't really have time to play
this I capture here he'll push but I
don't really mind yeah it seems like he
won but he didn't because I have checked
and then I pick up the pawn
okay good game okay so we got our three
points cuz we birth cert that so still
kind of in the top something Tommy cos
one would with a very nice rating he
probably came here to take this
tournament by storm so let's go be six
who will dethrone Magnus I don't think
in this cycle anyone just yet haven't
played this with with with f4 yet so
it's gonna be interesting if Bishop here
I'll just capture it forcing his queen
there c5 maybe a Leon iPhone I'm doing
great man
thank you for asking North Koreans are
simply better than Magnus Carlsen yeah
that's well said I'm just gonna ignore
this born I'm gonna make him figure out
what to do here
yeah that's okay that's one way to do it
he doesn't want to keep falling so I'm
stopping him from castling kingside
he will probably consider castling
queenside but we'll see Knight g5 is an
idea he's probably thinking about some
sort of a King side attack so I'll just
get rid of this Knight like immediately
I don't want to allow Knight g5 Queen h5
better get rid of it right away
he's probably thinking about Bishop
captures on h7 although that actually
wouldn't work that wouldn't work
thoughts about Wesley so he's a very
very chill guy I mean okay of course he
will capture it and now what's the idea
of he will check get the rook into the
game I don't think this ah
he has queen d3 yeah I thought he had
something but I thought he didn't
okay Queen Queen there definitely
definitely a good move good job man
if he castles which he will I do have an
open H file this is something to
consider on the other hand if he doesn't
and he won't but he will on the Queen
side it's very interesting I will get my
rook to c4 although he can just capture
it unfortunately unfortunately he can
simply capture it let's go Bishop a6 to
improve the rook c4 idea okay I'm not
really worried about any chicks here
I'll still play this
he's gonna try okay
now I definitely want to do what I want
to do a waiting move will be five seems
interesting if ya know okay now he can
double up that's that's true
h4 going for the kill immediately so
okay I'll simply how does he stop Queen
b6 he doesn't have a check anymore it's
interesting now he has to double up so
this kinda stops his attack at least for
the moment he's still better on time
though I might have some ideas of
pushing B for now he does have to play
rook rook here or Rock f1 or rugby one I
believe if he plays that I will put
before definitely but we'll see okay
he's even lower on time now so he's
probably considering moves like h5
that's something to consider alright but
I don't think it works yeah he does have
to play it like that so I guess I guess
I just want even more now would move
like this but this doesn't work so I
guess I don't want to lose any more time
so I move like this to definitely be
considered although now I allow h5
immediately that's pretty bad yeah I
can't allow him to open up this file
like that and before if he does have
that if I give up my rook
if I give up my rook that's a terrible
idea
it's actually a terrible idea yeah
what's the idea after this he will push
I can go here I think I can actually
play this like this maybe and capture
here ah Queen f6 yeah great
good job well deserved victory and and a
clean slate all the way to the end of
the tournament very nice ok I will try
it I will try this is probably the last
game so I'll try to berserk it to maybe
get into the top three although I don't
think I will be able to finish the game
that fast you will cannot okay let's
just put our bishop on h6 improve some
more and get our rocks into the game
ah okay just gonna pin it now didn't
even check if I had a tactic there I
don't think I did okay let's let's try
something here are always a good move
I'll try to I'll try to give up my rook
if he will be interested since don't
really okay I'll go h5 if you characters
here I'll simply capture on g6 you can't
really capture there since the rook is
hanging roki eight is out of the
question
ah okay I'll just capture it so it's
pretty unfortunately for him let's let's
just pin that bad boy so I do I'm
winning this game I just don't think it
will be it will be enough what's this Oh
G captures very nice
huh totally missed that although I don't
mind I mean I can I can win this no
problem yeah not too worried though
okay let's capture here play like this
like this and that's nuts like that okay
go up it's probably gonna try to push
one of the phones but it's not gonna
work I'll just capture this one here and
push the victory yeah let's get the
other one in there as well to prevent
any stale mating ideas okay a good game
yeah wasn't enough but a great
tournament although I will before I
announce the winners I will just wait a
couple of a minute or two because last
last tournament announce the winners end
and well the person who won the
tournament was actually the cheater
so I proclaimed him the victor on my
Facebook page and on my Twitter page and
then it's turned out that he cheated so
I'm not saying anyone here cheated I
just I just I'm just gonna wait a couple
of seconds maybe a minute or two do I do
drugs of course not mister nombre that
is a weird question indeed so I don't
know if I have to refresh it or anything
for for leeches to to detect any any
foul play but it seems like everything
is in order but okay I'll give it a
minute or two if you have any any non
weird questions no no not one more
tournament this is this is it for today
I will try and make one like a short one
every day
well alicia's bans the person who who
cheated and you if you lost to that
person you will get a message that your
rating has been refunded yeah it will be
a weekly tournament and like I said I
will make some sort of a website at
least a temporary one for now were you
know you will be able to check the
winners of the tournaments like in a
historic view or something yeah one more
video about Tull today definitely as
soon as as soon as I finished with the
stream definitely I'm gonna publish it
so I don't think anyone cheated here I'm
gonna refresh the page one more time and
that's pretty much it so yeah everything
seems to be in order mr. Tanaka's won
won the tournament with a perfect score
and 52 points with a rating performance
of 2206 100% win rate very nice
he won himself 661 rating points so I I
can assume he's he came from chess calm
or or maybe maybe just 24 or some other
website I don't know if Tommy costs one
is in the is in the chat I haven't seen
him have I heard about Eugene tour of
course since I don't see ah Thomas
Thomas - Ariana's your tummy cause you
are a filet master well then if you're a
feeder master your your score is well
justified well-played sir
congratulations do and in second place
we have Cinci goose with with a 93% win
rate rating performance of twenty one
hundred and seventy forty seven points
and xf-- is in third place with 37
points in fourth place it's Commodore 14
then myself in fifth just warning in
yeesh I ninety-nine and seventh maknae
in eighth Barra Mansa or bara mantra I
don't know in ninth and up diya aur ab
c-- a-- in place number ten also with a
pretty much everyone had a pretty pretty
clean streak so very nice game and like
i said congratulations once again to
Tomic us maybe it's Dom Akash I don't
know for winning the tournament with a
perfect score I will as usual announce
the winners and publish the results on
my Facebook and Twitter page so you know
you're all welcome to congratulate the
victors and that's it for this
tournament if anyone has any any
questions I will check out the chat I
did I did try and minion custody no H no
I'm not accepting any challenges after
this tournament but when I will make a
longer stream like a four hour streamed
and I will accept challenges for a three
hours no problem but this is only the
district is only for the purposes of the
tournament yes Dom Akash or tonica's was
was epic definitely hoped hope to see
him again in tournaments do I like
Justin Bieber of course not
who likes Justin Bieber man Fischer
Kasparov I do not want to answer that in
front of so many people am I gonna get a
cat when my dog dies well I'm probably
gonna get one even before that
the next tournament will probably be
tomorrow as as tomorrow is a good day
for a tournament definitely but if not
on Saturday definitely the next video is
already uploaded I just haven't
published it so Tomic us feed our
ratings
twenty three hundred and ten that's
that's okay that's very nice I'm glad
I'm glad we had a visit from from a feed
a master I don't know if you know Tama
cause but you can you can send a simple
request delicious and they will add a an
FM title to your atomic as one with the
shiny yellow letters if you if you enjoy
that an opening better for blades than
classical chess no not really
give a heads up for tournaments okay do
these quicker tournaments I don't really
have planned
although I do announce them on my
Facebook and Twitter page some half an
hour before the tournament starts and a
lot of people say that they didn't
receive a notification but you know it's
due to the new YouTube policy where you
have to click the little Bell button
it's not it's not enough just to be
subscribed that's you know it's pretty
bad
will I show more care as games well I I
will I mean I get a lot of requests
every day for a lot of players but my
tempo is two per day
do I like Sandra her song hehe I have no
idea who you are referring to send you
illusion off to another meeting with the
aliens
no no atomic us Tomica is not cheating
is a legit guy yeah no problem do I know
Simon act is team constants coach no I
don't I don't know him I do know of him
who would win Kasparov or Fischer
depends depends if you ask us part of
them Kasparov would win if you ask
Fischer then Fischer would win living in
Croatia is the best man - when the
tournament is over for now but probably
there will be one tomorrow
like I said I will announce it so yeah
that's pretty much it for this dream
thank you all for coming
I think we had even more players there's
tournament yet 320 players this is
definitely the record so far especially
for not for a tournament that was
announced like 15 minutes before it
started and almost 700 viewers so that's
also also 675 yours that's also a record
for this dream so thank you for coming
and you know for making this tournament
such a great tournament I mean 320
players that's that is one good
tournament yeah
thank you all for best wishes and for
watching I will see you soon and I'm I
will publish my next video about mikhail
tal it's quite a beasty game hope you
enjoy it so yeah that's it guys I'll see
you soon